bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui le
problème qu'on se pose c'est comment est
ce qu'on peut faire pour localiser un
point qui est à la surface de la terre
où qu'on soit jeu d'abord choisir un
point pour l'expérience ici un eto'o je
vais prendre un point ce point-ci et
maintenant voilà vous devez retrouver
sans le savoir ce point là donc juste
avec des informations de type d'un petit
message pour comment faire alors c'est
assez difficile mais heureusement les
géographes ont mis au point un système
très très efficace on va se servir de
deux références la première on va
prendre cette ligne imaginaire qui coupe
la terre en deux hémisphères
et ici elle est symbolisée par ce trait
noir de bien sûr c'est une île
imaginaire n'existe pas c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'équateur l'équateur c'est la
ligne qui est à égale distance du pôle
dehors qu'ici du pôle sud est ici en bas
à égale distance mais je trouve cette
ligne imaginaire qui aie l'équateur
premièrement je me posais la question
comment est ce que je peux faire pour
indiquer ce point là par rapport à
l'équateur alors comme la terre s
ferrique ne peut pas le faire en
kilomètres ce qu'il faut faire c'est
utiliser des ongles alors je vais mettre
ma terre comme ça et je vais faire comme
si je la coupe et endurant et mon point
est vraiment là sur le bord un prêt de
paiement support voilà et je fais comme
si je coupais en vue ce que j'obtiens
c'est ceux ci et là l'équateur est
toujours et le point j'aime une flèche
je les mentionnaient par une flèche par
rapport à ce point vous voyez l'équateur
se trouve à une amplitude de 40 degrés
j'ai un nez car j'ai un angle de 40
degrés entre l'équateur et la droite qui
part de ce point qui rejoint le centre
de la terre donc je vais pouvoir dire
dans un premier temps mais que ce point
est à 40 degrés de l'équateur vous avez
compris ce que c'est la honte de
l'équateur ça veut dire si on coupait la
plainte est rendu et aussi ont tracé des
droites jusqu'au centre de la terre on
aurait un oncle de 40 degrés entre
l'équateur et la droite du point donc on
va se dire que ce point est à une
latitude de 40° 40° de l'équateur
l'attitude toujours par rapport à
l'équateur
alors bien sûr la terre comme il ya du
côté
il ya 40 degrés ici et ya 40 degrés et
s'il ya aussi forcément un
si je retourne ses joueurs tout le monde
est sain évidemment j'ai 40 degrés rô
les 42 garde
alors comment faire pour me retrouver
bat simplement comme ici je suis dans
l'hémisphère nord
je vais dire que ce point est à 40
degrés au nord de l'équateur 40 degrés
de latitude nord
ok pour le point qui est ici quelques
par 40 degrés de latitude au sud de
l'équateur basse et 40 degrés de
latitude sud
ok voilà premières informations
alors vous allez me dire oui mais bon ce
point là et à 40 degrés au nord ce point
là ce point là en fait s'il fait tout le
tour il ya toute une série de points qui
forment un cercle autour de la terre qui
sont eux aussi à 40 degrés de latitude
nord
ça je suis bien d'accord avec vous et
vous avez raison de le remarquer parce
que tous ces points sont sur le même
réseau méridien un même parallèle par
dont tous les points qui ont une
latitude identiques sont sues situés sur
le même parallèle les parallèles ce sont
les droites imaginaire
1 les cercles imaginaire qui sont
parallèles à l'équateur d'accord donc
tous les points qui sont sur situé sur
un même parallèle ont la même latitude
comment est ce que je fais pour situer
alors le point avec précision mais je
vais utiliser un deuxième repères je
vais appeler un méridien et je vais
prendre le méridien qui passe ici par
londres londres et là vous avez un
méridien qu'est ce qu'un méridien c'est
une eau un demi-cercle qui part du pôle
nord qui passe par le point et qui
rejoint le pôle sud voyez ce sont les
lignes en fait qu'ils sont symbolisés
ici de manière verticale
voilà chaque fois ce sont les méridiens
et par rapport au méridien de greenwich
qui reste mon méridien de référence je
vais pouvoir faire la même chose que ce
que j'ai fait pour mon équateur
c'est-à-dire mesurer 1 11
alors ici voilà je vais trancher la
terre pour vous pour essayer des choses
voilà je remets mon poing au niveau de
mon axe d'accord le méridien de
greenwich est ici il passe ici et je
fais la même chose je fais comme si je
coupais
mater en dieu voilà le méridien de
greenwich je l'aligné bien ici en bas
pour ce soit bien clair pour vous voilà
donc le mégane greenwich il est bien ici
il passe là c'est mon point c'est mon
axe de rotation voiliers de repli si
j'ai une longitude cette fois-ci de 50
degrés et un écart de 50 degrés entre le
made in game which et la droite qui
passe par mon poing qui rejoint le
centre de la terre si je la coupe est
évidemment là on va parler de longitude
alors comme pour l'équateur dont il ya
deux côtés parce que si je fais tout le
tour de la terre à l'extrême opposé de
la terre ici vous voyez qui a le
méridien des 180 degrés alors la terre
est divisé en deux parties la partie
ouest et la partie est donc quand je me
trouvais à droite du méridien donc à
gauche pour nous là je vais parler de
longitude ouest
quand je vais être de l'autre côté je
vais parler de longitude est maintenant
donc pour localiser ce point je peux
parler très facilement d'un point qui
est située à une latitude de 40 degrés
nord est de 50 degrés ouest et de cette
manière je sais retrouverai mon point
ça c'est pour ce qui est d'une prouve
d'une terre qui se respecte mais moi
dans mon atlas commentait ce que je fais
pour me retrouver là voyez sur ma classe
j'ai aussi les lignes les méridiens et
les parallèles qui sont dessinés on
rappelle c'est toujours de l'imaginer
évidemment est ici sur le côté vous avez
les différentes latitudes qui sont
reprises ici 60 degrés latitude nord
dont tous les points qui sont ici sur ce
parallèle sont situés à une latitude de
60 degrés nord ont bien sûr ici j'ai pas
tout les parallèles qui sont mentionnés
ici je n'ai que celui de 60 celui des 50
ça veut dire que tous les points action
entre les deux sont en prune l'attitude
de 50 à 60 degrés de latitude nord 1 et
un point qui serait vraiment
à l'exact distance des deux parallèles
ça veut dire qu'il est à 55 ça y'a rien
de compliqué même chose pour la
longitude voyez les mentionner ici je
démarre de 180 puis forcément tout au
bout ici je repense à 170 180 à 170 160
etc jusqu'à 0 et j'arrive à ce méridien
qui passe bien près de londres à
greenwich donc par exemple ici si je
reprends le point qui était sur ma terre
tout à l'heure vous voyez ici je l'avais
mentionné
comment est ce que je fais pour le
retrouver ici j'avais dit que c'était à
une latitude de 40 degrés nord je
cherchais ma l'attitude 42 la nord elle
est la voix là et j'avais dit une
longitude de 50 degrés ouest le made in
a donc le point est exactement la 50
degrés ouest
voilà comment utiliser la latitude et la
longitude pour retrouver des points à la
surface du globe